all right so because it was a simple one
I reckon you guys might already have an
answer cause x equals minus 1
however think in your head of what cos x
looks like right ok I keep encouraging
you to go towards even if it's just a
simple one a graphical means of solving
these because it will rescue you from a
lot of problems when you've got your
graph in your head so where's the first
time that it's equal to minus 1 what
value in radius okay someone sit there
find X there it is okay so therefore
write my general solution like you
already notice is 2 n PI plus or minus
this is theta right so there's my pie
okay now this is kind of interesting
because since I apply in both of these I
could factorize right so you take that
ply out and you get this okay now very
very roughly sketching out a table for
this ok let's let's test out let's
generate our values here for N equals 0
1 2 3 what happens well I've got this
and I'm just going to be a bit cheap and
fast because I just want to illustrate a
point when you get for these values okay
what's going to happen for your first
one it's going to be 0 minus 1 inside
the brackets right so I'm gonna get -
boy yes I know this one I'm just gonna
get plus PI so faster good you go to the
next one over and you're like this is 2
minus 1 which is 1 so this is fine and
this will be 3 plus ok
and then this one will be 3 PI and this
sort of be 5 PI so you can see what a
carefully chosen subheading ok now these
two solutions overlap right so therefore
even though this is a correct general
solution okay you actually don't need to
write both of them you don't need to
write plus or minus because if you just
say 1 you'll have all the answers in the
other
so for instance I might just say that's
2m plus one now that's a bit weird
because these two equals lines they're
kind of not really equal right in that
plus or minus and possible the same
thing but for our purposes for general
solution they are equivalent okay
they'll generate the same set of
solutions now that's kind of tribute
like I mean it doesn't matter which way
you go but you start to run up against
different kinds of questions for it so
you'll get this question all right in
the textbook and you arrive at this
answer and you check it and it's all
fine you pop it back into your original
equation and it's all good and then you
look at the textbook and the answers
that are provided to you and it looks
totally different
hmm so how are we gonna know whether
your answer is right or not well let's
have a look at the example okay so
here's a second example now tell me
instinct what's the first thing that you
do to this equation yeah you've got
interesting issues we'll get to that
instinct in a second I mean the first
thing that I would do is on C it's a
product right so it's got its factorized
right so I can see this is two different
parts I can see it as sine X is equal to
zero and cos x is equal to zero okay
just like you are solving a quadratic
okay so you've got two different parts
to in factors so you saw okay
now let's have a look each of these has
its own general solution right general
solution for pi is M pi plus
switch okay and what's our relay today
we're going to be it's it's sine inverse
of zero in the first place that sign is
here is that doing okay all right now by
the way I should I should note down here
that I've introduced this number okay so
so far so good
yep that is an excellent question and
the answer is yes you absolutely must
write it okay
do you have to write this part yes yes
to do because because has a mark on what
I'm trying to get is does this person
get what general solution is about right
or as I was just looking at this morning
can you get some right answers but for
the wrong reasons like just by
coincidence
okay and I've been marking some you 12
papers that have just like that you've
got to be able to definitely understand
now the fact that it contributes nothing
to your final answer because it's a time
zero is it material right I wasn't I
want to see that you know what the
general solution is okay so yes I do
alright so there's one solution x equals
M pi so now you deal with this other
part over here okay what's the general
solution because okay now it is 2n pi
but because I'm already used in over
here I'm going to introduce another lab
so I'm gonna call it okay
I know usually we go forwards but always
so easily confused of zero that I'm
gonna wait it okay so I'm gonna call it
in and then you go plus or minus there
are they dangle which in this case it is
I on to okay and of course since I
introduced another letter I better say
what it is okay and yeah let's try it so
when you look at that there's not much
you do with it that's about it that's
all you can simplify okay it doesn't
really make anything
there's no profound like wow and I see
it so much more clearly now okay so I
think this is fine here's the
interesting thing on this question at
least a berry upon it appears in in this
exercise that I gave you and this is not
the answer
okay it gives you quite a different
answer now how can we how can we see
what the different answer is we're gonna
we're gonna go through Daniels first
instance which is that you can use an
identity to make this elusive one okay
namely I can convert that using double
angle yeah that's right I'll slap beyond
two out of the front now the cool thing
that this is to two really useful things
about it
number one I'm now solving with one
general solution not two so hard my work
already okay secondly this half at the
front I don't even need to worry about
it because I've got zero on the other
side so it's the same solution as to
this okay so that's kinda neat but
something's interesting when we actually
go ahead and solve this okay 2x is equal
to now my equations gonna look very
similar this right it's gonna be my yes
plus switch it's a power N and again
I've got sewer here so it's zero so I
get 2x equals n pi
on its part and so you divide by Sue and
you get this know these answers are
different if I approach it like this I
get this pair of answers I'll go up here
okay but if I use a different identity I
get a different answer at the end okay
but the thing is these really are the
same answer what if you can see it okay
we're going to generate the values just
to prove it okay so with this left-hand
side I've got one way of solving it to
way there's all the three ways of
solving it
okay so I'm going to draw up my table
here it's going to go in in the first
column okay and then over here I'm gonna
have my other three ways of actually
expressing the solution so I've got
Empire so this is actually M or - okay
so let's get some values out shall we
let's just do this column because it's
super easy okay it's gonna be 0 lots of
pie 1 lot of pie to multiply so far so
good
okay what happens in this column here
well our first value is actually going
to send us into the okay but when you go
forward to pie
you're gonna get 3/5 right right yeah
and you go forward another 2 pi you're
going to get seven pilot ooh is that
check out yeah that in for planetary
choice all right now we rehearse it with
this comma positive pi/2 first value add
another 2 pi and then add another 2 pi
okay so now you can see these are all
the solutions we get out of these two
green branches as it were
let's test it out with this one over
here I'm going to get and keep
forgetting if I figure then you probably
will forget it so make a big note that
every time you actually write down your
general solution
I've got a traditional book all right
yes that's the reader I think it's
actually a capital epsilon I think
double check that with your brief okay
all right now let's test out these
values 0 1 2 let's go all the way that
far so when you put in 0 0 you put in 1
you get high - you're put into it yeah -
part 2 which is high I am seeing a
pattern okay so how far do I need to go
so you satisfied that we didn't do
anything wrong
ok these two different ways I got to
give us a same set of solutions now you
tell me which do you prefer
yeah I prefer this one - okay we said
not only does it have the advantage of
you're solving one equation rather - but
even the answer itself is what elegant
okay it just catches them all and you
have to be careful when you're checking
your answers and the answer you get
disagrees with the answer that they give
you here's what you do draw up your
table of values check them all out right
draw up their tip of those and compare
those ok now in this case I reckon now
that you're sort of
clued into it if you looked at this and
then you looked at these two without
generating the total values I think you
might be able to see yeah I could sort
of see that you know this is gonna have
more solutions to it every every half a
pie I'm getting one whereas this it's
sort of like covering the apps okay
other times it's not so more obvious so
obvious so these are that must be the
write down this is the question I'd like
you to do which is actually question 32
you know set but I want you all to do it
now it's sine 4x minus sine 2x equals
zero sine 4x minus sine 2x equals zero
has anyone done it yet questions 32 okay
that's why that's right that's great I
want you all to have it go in it come up
with a solution and then I want you to
generate a table values and compare it
with the answer that they get and in a
few minutes I'll show you how I do it if
we have time